welcome back to CBS mornings it was a
Monumental day yesterday and Monumental
is a word here in the case of Adnan Syed
his story was featured in the 2014
podcast serial now last month he was
freed by a judge after spending more
than 23 years in prison for the murder
of his ex-girlfriend that's Heyman Lee
now prosecutors have just announced they
are dismissing all charges this is such
a big deal they say newly tested
evidence exonerates him even so not
everyone believes that he is innocent
darika Duncan has been following this
case
today Justice is done a state attorney
for Baltimore City Maryland Mosby
apologized yesterday to the families of
both Adnan Syed and hey Min Lee as she
announced her office's decision to drop
all charges against Syed he was tried as
an adult at just 17 for strangling and
killing his 18 year old ex-girlfriend
but subsequent investigations cast
doubts on his conviction last month in a
stunning reversal prosecutors asked a
judge to vacate the guilty verdict and
release him from prison they said that
in 1999 there were two alternative
suspects both with histories of violence
against women and one who even
threatened Lee but that information was
never shared with syed's defense team
the judge agreed and gave prosecutors 30
days to decide whether or not to retry
the case and they're now going one step
further saying that newly tested items
from the crime scene exonerate cyan
there was
a DNA mixture of multiple contributors
on both Miss Lee's shoes and most
compellingly Adnan Saeed
his DNA was excluded Syed who's now 41
has always maintained his innocence
his murder conviction first gained
national attention in 2014 when the
podcast serial chronicled this case and
some of its irregularities even
featuring and interviewed with Syed from
prison
come with any type of proof or anecdote
or anything to ever say that I was ever
mad at her that I was ever
angry with her that I ever threatened
her meanwhile an attorney for the family
of Heyman Lee expressed their
disappointment at what they call the
prosecution's sudden reversal of syed's
conviction for CBS mornings jerika
Duncan New York